so you'll see I'm almost finished I have
just left the critical step off this one
and then I will show you the other way
of proving Ecuador you might have
noticed is substantially faster but
that's okay so you can see I've just got
my straight substitution I've expanded
out using my trig identities everything
is fine I get to this point why is this
quite an important point to pause I'm
about to evaluate some limits that's a
critical step right so you've got this
guy you know what happens to this this
is identical to what you had over here
right so we know you know they're both
going toward zero when you compare the
numerator in the denominator the
numerator gets to zero faster much much
faster so that's why the whole thing
ends up being zero so you're gonna get
cos x times zero takeaway sine x times
one
okay so you can see all right you
differentiate sign you get cosine the
differentiate cosine you don't get back
to side you get back to negative sign
and of course it must be done because we
look at this you think about what cosine
looks like right yes okay when you think
about the gradient have a look at the
first PI radians of the graph the first
PI radians within that domain is cosine
an increasing or decreasing function and
it's clearly decreasing so therefore
it's gradient function has to be
underneath here it can't be up here that
doesn't make sense right so when
students because they they do confuse
between like which one gets the minus
signs like which one is that this one to
that or is it that one side
differentiate sine get to negative cos
think about what it looks like you'll be
fine if you think of a picture it has to
be this right because it's decreasing
and then it's increasing that's the way
I visualize that so I did say if you did
it the other way it was substantially
faster because if if you differentiate
cause by considering as a compatible so
if you differentiate rather than cause
you differentiate this okay this is just
general right it's just chain rule so
when you do the inside function what's
the derivative of the inside it's just
negative one and then you do the outside
but we just decided that sign turns into
cosine right so it just becomes this
there's that instant inside function is
still there but but wait a second we're
just sure I know what that is that's
sign and you are there in some pretty
decent time okay now one last result we
got signed in first principles we did
cosine either the long way or you went
to the chain rule 10 of course now 10
pulls out pretty quickly when you
remember the ten of course is just to
find out sine over cos so this is actual
going to appeal to questions now that
sounds terrible
we hate cushion rule we avoid it
everywhere we possibly can but watch
what happens right because we know what
each of the individual derivatives is v
you - there's me what's your - it's just
cosine so I'm gonna get cos squared
agree take away you UV - that's sine X
we just showed that's minus sine X so
there's minus signs when an X do you
agree with that all over V squared which
is consequent yeah but you can see
what's happening on the numerator right
cos squared plus sine squared this is
the familiar Pythagorean identity so
this is one and by convention we write
this as SEC square sir put a big box
around the derivative of sine is cosine
the derivative of cosine is negative
sine and the derivative tan is sec
square and then of course you can
combine these with all of the product
rule quotient rule chain impressions you
already know
for instance I could ask you what's the
derivative all let's just do a simple
one to begin with sine 2x this is a
chain rule right what you gonna do to it
you're going to do the inside which is
and then you're gonna do the outside
which is Plus done that was my hot how
about how about we do something like
this can you differentiate for me if I
sweat how would you rewrite that
this is cos x squared right
so this is again chain rule but in a
different direction so I'm going to do
the inside which is minus size and then
I'm going to do the outside which is
bring the power down and reduce the
power by one which looks to me like
minus 2 sine x cos x that sounds like
this doesn't it I know that that was
necessarily a sexual button okay so I
can keep on doing this I could do here's
an interesting one about this one wall F
- on earth right Oh F - on influence F
dash minus sign what's it's that so
that's this and I could do this for a
long time right you see now that you
know more different kinds of functions
you can put them together in more
different ways it's just like getting
more Laker and the number of things you
can have pun intended increases
exponentially right so this is actually
this is the second last major category
of functions that we will ever learn how
to differentiate or as we go on to in a
couple days integrate the last category
is in verse 3 if say our world trig
that's pretty true it would be that
different right we will get all of those
results out of these but they end up
being quite different beasts as we're
seeing when we get there